I want to talk a little bit today about the
entire let's open on Easter delusion that
Donald Trump wanted with packed churches,
which now is not going to happen as medical
doctors have explained to Trump.
We at least have to stay shut down until April
30th.
And so Donald Trump, obviously, he wants to
reopen things as soon as possible.
He wants to let it rip as soon as possible.
He thinks it will be good for approval and
good for the economy and good for his reelection
possibilities.
And Trump specifically was looking at Easter,
which again has now been canceled.
With this narrative of packed churches on
Easter, because there is an element of Trump
wanting to be seen in a Jesus like way, he
has a sort of God complex of Trump as the
reser rector of the United States.
On Easter, Trump equates this idea of him
miraculously reopening the country on Easter
as a sort of second coming of Christ of a
sort.
Trump imagines this scenario where we're shuttered
and closed down.
We are in a winter literally and metaphorically,
and then it becomes spring as it now is, and
he will take the country back to being open
on Easter.
Christians will fill churches and pray not
just to God, but to Trump, defying him as
a pseudo godlike figure.
That entire rebirth story is a very popular
story with Christians and Easter perfectly.
Brant blends that resurrection of Jesus with
the resurrection of the United States.
Now, it's not happened, and clearly it didn't
make sense from the get go.
And doctors have convinced Trump of that.
But the level of delusion and God complex
that the president has combined with his complete
inability to ever take responsibility for
anything, it's not just sad.
It's not just tragic.
It's actually a danger.
And, you know, with everything that we know,
the virus takes 10 to 14 days between incubation
and until symptoms start.
If Trump did this and we were reaching the
peak right around Easter, as we are expected
to do, we might have actually seen a slight
decline.
If Trump did this for a few days, which would
have fueled his belief that he did the right
thing.
But then around April 25th, we would have
seen a rapid upshot in the number of new cases
and deaths because of the delayed effect of
the contagion.
So it's a very good thing that Trump decided
not to do this.
But the degree to which Trump is starring
in a reality show of his own making, where
he increasingly casts himself as a D.A. of
sorts while science and rationality crumble
around Trump is very, very scary.
I started searching around the Internet to
see whether my suspicions about this God complex
were right.
And in fact, you already had evangelicals
posting on Reddit and on Twitter.
Stuff like Trump is going to raise the nation
from the dead on Easter, just like Jesus rose
from the dead.
Here's a reminder, by the way, of Trump talking
about why he wanted Easter at the packed churches,
by the way.
But Ortolan is never going to be like being
there.
So I think Easter Sunday and you'll have packed
churches all over our country.
I think it would be a beautiful time.
And it's just about the timeline that I think
is right.
It gives us more chance to work on what we're
doing.
And I'm not sure that's going to be the day,
but I would love to aim it right at Easter
Sunday.
So we're open for church service and services
generally on Easter Sunday.
That would be a beautiful thing.
So we would all have suffered greatly because
of that God complex that Trump presents there.
Trump again, imagining parishioners thanking
Trump nationwide.
Of course, in advance of what would have been
an even more escalated, more quickly escalating
caseload and death toll.
And it's a form of the Christian dominionism
that we've been talking about on our show
for a long time.
It's embodied by Trump, who, again, I don't
believe for a second is religious personally,
but he's successfully tricked many of his
followers into believing that he is.
And meanwhile, of course, case numbers have
continued to explode, looking very ugly.
My hope is and I don't know whether this will
happen, that by the middle to end of this
week, we might start to see a reduced growth
factor.
That doesn't mean new case numbers will decrease
in the net in the aggregate, in the raw numbers,
but maybe the growth rate might decrease where
I'm hoping.
But we had nineteen thousand new cases on
Saturday confirmed, of course, many, many
more in reality.
About 19000 confirmed cases yesterday.
On Sunday.
On Saturday we had five hundred and twenty
five deaths.
Yesterday, thankfully, a decrease to only
a little under 300 deaths.
But questions about whether those are really
being correctly tracked if someone dies of
respiratory distress.
Is it being counted as a corona virus, death
or not?
And this is a sort of death certificate thing
that Anthony Foushee actually spoke about
during a recent interview.
That's a very specific detail.
It has all been going wrong.
Trump making the right decision not to open
on Easter and Trump clearly being convinced
by the doctors around him that his God complex
wanting to be defied on Easter by evangelical
Christian followers, packing churches and
praying not just to God, but also to Trump,
did not outweigh the fact that we need to
be shut down for an additional 30 days, 32
days from today.
That's what we know as of now.
Let me know.
You're thinking about the 30 days, the 32
days from now.
I'm on Twitter at the Packman.
We'll take a break.